on voit leur publicité partout elles
sont accessibles en quelques clics
souvent hébergé dans des paradis fiscaux
les plateformes privées de jeux en ligne
de frayeur chemin jusque chez nous même
si elles sont considérées illégales au
Québec c'est important pour le
gouvernement d'arriver en 2023 et de
réaliser que le système actuel est
complètement désuet Nathalie Bergeron
représente une coalition de 8 opérateurs
privés qui offre des paris sportifs et
des jeux de casino en ligne sur des
plateformes très populaires comme
PokerStars bet nine ou encore fan de
Wall elles veulent être encadrées par le
gouvernement du Québec avec un système
de licence comme l'a fait l'Ontario l'an
dernier il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui s'adonnent à ces activités là c'est
du divertissement mais c'est aussi un
activité qui peut engendrer des
comportements à risque donc en
s'assurant de standardiser les normes de
jeux responsables on assure on augmente
la protection des consommateurs elle
fait valoir que Québec j'aurais du même
coup exigé des redevances sur les
revenus générés et mettre la main sur
une jolie cagnotte on pense que c'est
plus de 230 millions par année que le
gouvernement peut aller chercher l'idée
est vue d'un mauvais œil par Loto-Québec
qui détient le monopole des jeux de
hasard sur le web dans la province l'an
dernier elle a récolté 391 millions de
dollars sur sa plateforme espace jeux ce
qui représente 17 % de ses revenus un
montant 10 fois plus élevé qu'en 2013
pour nous le modèle étatique est celui
qui est le plus approprié le plus
sécuritaire et le plus contrôlé affirme
la société d'État Loto-Québec est la
seule à pouvoir opérer un site de paris
sportifs et de casino en ligne 100%
légal le seul site de paris sportif est
de casino 100% légal et locales ça reste
au Québec je connais tous les pièges du
jeu la directrice générale de la Maison
Jean Lapointe où l'on traite des joueurs
compulsifs s'opposent aussi à la
légalisation des plateformes privées
l'impact que ça peut avoir une
augmentation de l'offre de jeu en ligne
parce qu'actuellement ces sites-là étant
illégaux il y a quand même une partie de
la population qui ose pas aller sur ces
sites-là et qui s'en tiennent au site
d'espace jeux de Loto-Québec mais la
coalition a une bonne carte en main un
rapport d'experts commandé par Québec et
publié en 2014 parmi les recommandations
qui n'ont jamais été appliquées
réglementées les plateformes privées de
jeux de hasard en ligne si le professeur
Louise Nadeau qui a présidé les travaux
quand on a fait cette étude là notre
constatation a été que la meilleure
protection qui existe présentement c'est
des maîtres des licences si on avait un
organisme de réglementation alors cette
organisme aurait un ensemble de pouvoirs
qui permettrait effectivement de
protéger les plus vulnérables et de
s'assurer que les Dieu est une intégrité
je pense que le Québec on est un peu à
la traîne qu'au triste du rapport de
2014 Sylvia keroz pense qu'un système de
licence supervisé par un organisme
indépendant permettrait de baliser les
plateformes privées pour mieux protéger
les joueurs à risques limités
le temps de jeu etc chaque fois qu'il y
a un nouveau jeu qui va apparaître il
passe sous la loupe du régulateur pour
s'assurer de sa son seuil de risque et
les jeux qui sont trop risqués des fois
l'opéra le régulateur va empêcher leur
commercialisation selon une étude
qu'elle a mené le jeu en ligne a explosé
au Québec pendant la pandémie 15% des
joueurs jouent maintenant devant un
écran si trois fois plus qu'auparavant
un constat qui inquiète puisque près
d'un joueur en ligne sur 5 présente un
risque élevé ou modéré des prouver des
problèmes reliés au jeu avec des
chiffres comme ça n'importe quelle autre
phénomène on aurait vraiment pesé sur le
bouton panier
peut être à l'abri tu peux être isolé
pour jouer personne va le savoir tu peux
jouer 24 heures sur 24
[Musique]
gouvernement va entamer une réflexion
sur le réglementation des plateformes en
ligne ou s'il va continuer de miser sur
le système actuel